[Musique]
faut frapper vite et fort avec un
principe très simple aujourd'hui il n'y
a plus d'ambiguïté possible il faut
faire le jeu aujourd'hui il faut faire
des jeux et bien je vous le dis on doit
interdire toute association qui se
réclament de l'islam et qui ne
condamnerait pas publiquement clairement
ce crime abject on doit interdire et
fermer toutes mosquées qui ne
condamnerait pas clairement et
publiquement ce crime abject j'ajoute
que très concrètement cette question de
du séparatisme et de la laïcité elle
s'invite mais dans toutes nos vies très
récemment j'ai reçu de la défenseur des
droits aucune institution qui est censé
défendre les valeurs de la république
une injonction changer les règlements de
baignade des piscines des îles de
loisirs de la région ile-de-france pour
autoriser le burqini alors il faut
savoir que dans nos baignade en aux îles
de loisirs nous avions des femmes qui
voulait se baigner habillé il ya
quelques années donc on avait interdit
on avait dit pour des raisons d'hygiène
de sécurité et d'ordre public on aura
des baignades en maillot piscine c'est
clair c'est net c'est la tradition
française on se baigne en maillot de
fichiers aujourd'hui le défenseur des
droits nous demandent bien vous tapez
sur les wii et il nous accuse de
discrimination pour motifs religieux
mais il inverse en réalité le
raisonnement il nous demande c'est lui
qui nous demande pour des motifs
religieux de changer les règlements qui
sont des règlements d'hygiène et de
sécurité donc on voit que cette question
du séparatisme elle est pas encore et de
la laïcité de quelle est notre vision si
des femmes pas toutes ces questions là
elle mérite encore de faire l'objet
d'une vraie formation au niveau à tous
les niveaux de ce que je crois c'est que
le port du voile forcé dans l'espace
public doit être interdite et
sanctionnée
ça veut dire qu' aucune femme dans notre
pays ne doit être forcés de porter ce
qui n'est pas seulement un signe
religieux ce qui est un signe de
soumission de la femme donc on ne doit
pas forcer à porter le voile li les
adultes ni les fillettes j'ai des
principes qui ne sont pas négociables
le premier c'est que vous ne trouverez
toujours aux côtés d'un professeur
lorsqu'il est mis en cause
menacée par des islamistes toujours
quelle que soit la ville quel que soit
le moment je serai toujours à ses côtés
pour le défendre ça c'est le premier
principe le deuxième principe c'est que
lino écoles sont des sanctuaires et nos
écoles sont des sanctuaires ça veut dire
que je condamne vigoureusement
l'irruption du maire de ses adjoints
pour distribuer des tracts contre le
professeur pour monter les élèves contre
un professeur menacé par les islamistes
dans l'iss et de trappes c'est pour ça
que j'ai demandé la suspension de
l'équipe municipale ces principes
républicains ces principes fondamentaux
et on peux pas y renoncer parce que si
on y renonce ça veut dire qu'on baisse
la tête si on baisse la tête on se
soumet et moi je ne me soumettrai j'aime
quand on jette en pâture des enseignants
et qu'on les accuse sans aucune preuve
en leur mettant quasiment une cible dans
leur dos je considère que c'est du
terrorisme intellectuel c'est du
terrorisme intellectuel moi en ce qui me
concerne je suis évidemment aux côtés de
ses professeurs qui sont accusés à tort
qu'ils sont cloués au pilori c'est de
l'appel à la délation qui a été fait
dans l'institut de sciences politiques
de grenoble